Speaker 1: All right.
A truly blockbuster media story.
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones has
been ordered to pay nearly $1,000,000,000
in his latest trial.
Flipped out, started requesting money from
his audience.
We are going to look at the verdicts and this
is just unbelievable.
The Associated Press article on the screen
lays out the specifics.
Alex Jones ordered to pay $965 million for
his Sandy Hook lies.
Jurors ordered Jones to pay nearly $1,000,000,000
to Sandy Hook Elementary School shooting victims
relatives and an FBI agent who said he turned
their loss and trauma into years of torment
by promoting the lie that the rampage was
a hoax.
This is the second big judgment against Jones
for spreading the myth that the deadliest
school shooting in history never happened.
The verdict came in a defamation suit filed
by some of the families of 26 people killed
in that 2012 shooting, plus an FBI agent among
the first responders.
You may recall we covered it and spoke to
lawyer Mark Bankston.
A Texas jury in August awarded nearly $50
million to the parents of another slain child,
Robbie Parker.
Remember, Robbie Parker lost his six year
old daughter, Emily.
He's one of the people that Alex Jones suggested
was a so-called crisis actor.
Here is an incredible moment, the verdicts
being read in the courtroom.
Speaker 3: Ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
please listen to your verdict at read the
verdict.
We the jury have reached a verdict as to damages
in this case, the award damages to each plaintiffs
and against Alex Jones and Free Speech Systems
LLC as follows.
Volume one Advances toward Damages.
Instructions fill in both numbers for each
plaintiff, then go to section two to center
damage damages the specimens for each plaintiff
on the lines belong to plaintiff Robbie Carter.
A defamation slash slander damages past future
$60 million b emotional distress damages past
and future $60 million.
Wow.
Total fair, just and reasonable damages to
plaintiff Robert Parker and against Alex Jones.
And free speech systems have my name.
I'd be $120 million.
The initial value juror number one to plaintiff
David Wheeler A defamation class slander damages
based on future $25 Million.
The emotional distress damages past and future,
the $30 million total fair and reasonable
damages to plaintiff David Wheeler and against
Alex Jones and free speech systems at nine
nationwide.
B $55 million of.
Speaker 1: These verdicts continued and continued
and continued and different plaintiffs being
awarded varying amounts of money.
Remember what Attorney Marc Bankston told
us when I interviewed him a few weeks ago,
that these subsequent cases would end Infowars.
They would end Infowars.
Now, Alex Jones says that that's not going
to happen.
And he immediately, immediately took to the
airwaves and started asking for money, essentially.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: They want to scare everybody away
from freedom and scare us away from questioning.
You've all day and when it really happened,
there are parkland or any other event.
And guess what?
We're not scared and we're not going away
and we're not going to stop.
And literally for hundreds of thousands of
dollars, I can keep them in court for years.
I can appeal this stuff.
We can stand up against this travesty, against
the billions of dollars they want.
It's a joke.
So please go to Infowars store dot com and
get vitamin mineral fusion.
Get x three.
Speaker 1: Right give the solution to this
travesty is getting vida mineral fusion.
Speaker 5: All the great products that are
there that keep us on air and Infowars store
dot com yeah hey.
Speaker 1: So I don't know whether this will
end Infowars.
You know, one of the questions I had for plaintiffs
attorney Mark Bankston, who was involved in
the Texas case, was, what about collecting
the money?
Okay, you got it.
You got a judgment.
You got a verdict.
How do you collect the money?
He said, without going into detail that as
attorneys they have ways of doing that and
that they will collect the vast majority of
this money now.
Does Alex Jones have $1,000,000,000?
Not from everything I knew.
But is the whole point that the verdict exceeds
his actual assets by so much that it will
completely end Infowars?
Now, to be clear, I think it's important to
say it's not about taking pleasure in the
financial demise of Jones or Infowars necessarily.
It's more that there has to be some responsibility
for people who have public platforms, and
I include myself in this.
There has to be some responsibility and accountability,
and the financial and legal problems should
correlate with the degree to which your actions
are deplorable, wrong, dishonest and unethical.
Jones Actions over the last many years be
going beyond even the Sandy Hook fiasco have
been the lowest of the low.
And so it is just that the financial and legal
consequences are commensurate with that.
That's the point.
Not about cheerleading someone's financial
ruin.
We will follow it.
We will see what can be collected.
And there are more cases coming, folks.
This is not
the
end of it.